Now I want to take some time to
show you how to use variables and
constants in a playground.
I've gone ahead and
opened this empty playground,
and we'll get started by
declaring some variables.
We know to create a variable that we
need to use something like the following
syntax.
We have the keyword var, then some
name for the variable, and its value.
For example,
I'll create this variable called
mJerseyNumber with the value of five.
This creates or declares a variable
with the name myJerseyNumber, and
when we write this code,
Swift works behind the scenes and
infers that myJerseyNumber's type is
an integer, because five is an integer.
And we can check this if we
hold down the option key, and
we go up to the variable name, and
we click it, we can see that it's
been declared as an int value.
When Swift automatically infers
the type of the variable,
in this case the int,
We call this inferred typing.
So let's do another example.
So we'll create this variable
called myCoolVariable and
give it a value of a in double quotes.
So if you've created a variable like
this before where you used the double
quotes, you may already know what Swift
may infer this to be, but we can check.
And it looks like Swift has interpreted
this as a string variable, so
myCoolVariable contains a string,
and that makes sense.
That's what these double quotes mean.
That means a string.
But this string is just one character.
What if we wanted the variable
to be of character type,
because it represents a single
character instead of a string type,
which can represent multiple characters.
Is there a way that we
can help Swift do this?
Actually, there is, and here's how.
We'll modify our
variable declaration and
add a colon after the name, and
then specify the type that we want.
So this is a slightly different
syntax than we saw before, but
it removes the need for
Swift to guess the variable's type
because we're explicitly stating it.
In this case,
we want it to be a character.
And when we take the guesswork
out of typing for
Swift, we call this explicit typing.
And if I use the option click, we can
see that this is now a character and
no longer a string.
In general, Swift does a great job at
inferring the types of our variables, so
explicit typing is
usually not necessary.
However, in some cases like this one,
you want to use explicit typing so
that the compiler knows exactly what
type you intend for the variable.